what is going on with Bitcoin why is
this coin not moving
because we have a lot of news from China
China's economy is in trouble the
dollars has been moving up
check this out so what is bitcoin not
moving now okay usually when this
happens it's either because the market
is waiting for some news announcements
uh this week we only have on Thursday
pce inflation report a non-farm payrolls
on Friday
uh of course you know they are big news
announcements but I don't think that the
market is waiting for them because if
you go for example to the dollar and you
check the four hours sorry well the four
hour time frame yes you see that it's
moving up okay you see that it's moving
and it's probably gonna go
to watch this Zone over here
in the next few hours okay
okay you have their liquidity pool so
you know the dollar is moving why is
Bitcoin not moving that's why I don't
think that is because the news
announcements then something is proven
here there is something going on here
now if you go to the Daily time frame
the first thing that gets my attention
are all these fixed to the downside here
but price is not continue going lower
okay if you notice here you have like a
weak Zone
and price keeps spiking down and then
reversing
what does that usually happen well
usually this means that the market maker
is building a position in this case that
would be building logs for the same
reason that I don't think
that this is varies okay I don't think
that this is where is all those weeks
right but for the same reason that for
example here
I didn't think that this was bullish
okay or let's continue
I also didn't think that this was
bullish for this or this or that this
was very showcase you can see that when
they set weeks towards One Direction
usually the highest or the lows but it
doesn't break through
it means that there is an intention for
the market maker to hold a position and
build a reversal okay so
um that's the first thing that gets my
attention there is a possibility on this
if I'm wrong that the market Main kit is
prepared enough for a reversal
okay
also if you go to the forward hours time
frame they're gonna see it here also
quite clearly okay let's even reverse
the chart that's do reverse chart you
have here
one hit to the upside
this is the second top to the upside
and what about if you see guys another
hit to the upside here what is reverse
so that will be to the downside okay
another hit here
and then that's when you can see a
reversal okay three top spot and you
know the theory okay three tops pattern
why couldn't we see still something like
this of course I would have rather to
see this yesterday and I'll tell you
okay that's Monday false move
because you would have the Confluence of
the timing but it's Monday false move
durso would have the Confluence of the
three tops button and also the weeks in
the daily time frame to the downside by
not breaking through so you would have a
lot of confluence
to open along here and wait for a
reversal towards the mid-range okay this
doted line over here now of course today
is Tuesday yesterday didn't happen
Market maker watching all my tweets and
videos so didn't want to give me that uh
trait but I still think about that there
is a high chance that happens okay uh
maybe even as low as last week's lows
which is here around 25 300 okay there
is a chance that happens one hit two
hits
three hits
reversal so that's what it is for now
what I'm what I'm looking at okay uh of
course you know if price decides not to
pull from here
then you have here the 15 minute photos
time frame that I also mentioned this
Sunday Bitcoin update uh by the way you
don't follow me on Twitter
um I think it's worth it just for those
Bitcoins on the updates because we are
trying to prepare ourselves for the next
week ahead and we've been doing this for
the last year and a half so
um I would recommend you to to follow me
there probably most of you do already
but that's a reminder okay but anyway if
price is accessible from here and it
doesn't give us this entry over here
okay and then it bounces from here okay
so if price just points from here then
the next thing you can take would be
this retrace
to the 4 Hour 50ma okay you can take
this three trees and aim for the mid
range then okay so that's what I'm
looking in the Bitcoin chart ideally I
want to see uh a reversal here in the
very short term uh hopefully you can see
these three tops button
okay something like this and then the
reversal but if that doesn't happen and
price goes up from here then you have
the retrace to the 50ma
and then you can Target the mid-range
but that's in the very short time
because then if you go for example to
the weekly time frame
in high time frame I've been telling you
this doesn't look good
you are right now below the weekly 50ma
uh the only support that you have right
now is the range low so if you lose this
level
if you lose the range lows then you are
gonna go
towards probably this week over here
around 20 700.
because yes we have a week that is not
filled and what are the chances that
this week remains fulfilled uh two three
percent
so the odds are against it it should get
filled okay that's what I think in the
higher time frame that doesn't mean that
still we could see in the short term a
small shorter squeeze and then some
consolidation here for maybe a couple of
weeks and then you can see the breakout
to the downside okay something like that
is what I'm looking for at the moment
with Bitcoin so let's check now High
block capital
let's see where the liquidity is one
example Capital liquidation levels let's
see if this loads
come on
that it is okay the Delta is right now
um well in shorts so liquidation
cumulative one and a half billion
dollars worth of salt liquidation is not
much it's pretty much neutral to say
though so it's not telling me much but
if then if you check the spikes at the
right of this chart you can notice that
the spikes are to the upside so that
means well specifically this one over
here
127 million dollars worth of Sword
liquidations are 26 850.
so the chart is telling you the very
small report to the website okay now if
we go into the liquidation hit map and
we check the seven days time frame you
can see that right now we are below two
liquidation zones so you have to do
upside 27k and then to the downside you
have two zones you have 25 700 that goes
all the way to 25 600 potential three
tabs pattern soon
all right and if we continue going lower
one we break below this Zone then you
have 25 100 so would it make sense to
first hit this one at 25 600 ish
hit that soon reverse the 27k and then
at 25k that is gonna be a lot more of
liquidity but
especially in the higher time frame
there is a a lot of liquidity here uh 23
500.
and also in the three months time frame
there is a lot this is the most
interesting chart in my opinion there is
a lot of 24 200 so now imagine for a
second what happens if
price goes to 25 600 or so then pumps at
27k
okay we're in that pump
that's when the retailers want to open
Longs okay not before that that's when
the retail Traders want to open longs
and if the return is open in Longs what
happens to this zone of 24 200 well
simply the liquidity here will increase
and it's gonna get bigger and bigger and
bigger so when the market make it then
reverse and brings price back down and
hit this soon
a lot more liquidations that they could
have done previously
okay so that's the market theory that I
have right now in the short term in the
midterm and also in the long term
so thank you so much for watching guys
and I'll see you soon